c'est la photo du jour avec pour légende
trois hommes et un coup politique plutôt
fin denis thuriau sans étiquette
philippe cordier ump et guillaume
maillard udi tous les trois rassemblés
sous la même bannière pour faire
basculer nos verres une bannière celle
de la liste indépendante nevers à venir
mené par le moins encartés détroit mais
le plus fort en termes de voix denis
thuriau les personnes qui nous
rejoignent les nouveaux colistiers
puisque notre liste doivent être déposés
seront sans étiquette nous rejoignent
sur notre programme qui n'a pas bougé
d'un iota et donc c'est effectivement
nos verres à venir qui est désormais
porter de l'espoir de ce changement pour
nevers qui sera très salutaire pour tous
denis thuriau et le leadership de la de
la liste et c'est lui qui ne le quittent
va d'arriver cette liste celui qui sera
notre maire l'ump cordier en septième
place et lui dei maillard en 5e ranger
derrière l'indépendant denis thuriau
vous a si bien une prise de guerre comme
le parti socialiste et ses alliés
pouvaient la redoute et la réplique ne
s'est pas fait attendre plutôt cinglante
dans le camp du maire ps sortant ma
réaction c'est d'abord de dire que les
choses sont claires les masques sont
tombés et nous avons une liste de droite
mais même qui fait une alliance avec la
droite la plus dure
donc les choses sont parfaitement
claires et j'ai une vraie tristesse je
dois dire à constater cette manoeuvre de
mes adversaires parce que les électeurs
les noeuds vers soi et c'est très grave
ont été trompés au premier tour en
rebattant les cartes denis thuriau
complique énormément la tâche pour
florent sainte fare garnot le maire ps
sortant à la calculette
c'est nevers à venir qui arrive
désormais en tête avec plus de 48% des
voix contre 35% réalisé par l'alliance
ps pc et europe ecologie les verts
pour le second tour toutes les voies
vont désormais compter les petites
listes battu au premier prg et lutte
ouvrière pourrait même jouer les
arbitres avec 5% des suffrages
recueillis
de son côté la liste bleue marine fn
également présente au second tour à
nevers se frotte les mains en pensant
récupérer des voix de la droite qui ne
digérera pas la fusion thuriau